Nicolás y Alicia hicieron una competencia de escalada en muro.
La altura de Alicia sobre el suelo está dada por la ecuación,
"a" es igual a un tercio de "t" más 5,
donde "a" es la altura de Alicia medida en metros
"t" es el tiempo transcurrido desde el inicio de la competencia en segundos.
Nicolás comenzó a escalar al mismo tiempo que Alicia
y también lo hace con una velocidad constante.
Su altura sobre el suelo en diversos momentos se ilustra en la siguiente tabla,
aquí le dan el tiempo en segundos
que ha transcurrido
y esta es la altura de Nicolás en metros.
¿Quién empezó la carrera
en un punto más alto del muro?
Supongo por la pregunta
que alguno de los dos será mejor
y le dio ventaja
a la otra persona o algo así.
Pero bueno,
para hacer esto para contestar esta pregunta,
lo que tengo que hacer
es encontrar la altura de ambos en el tiempo, "t" igual a 0,
que fue cuando comenzó la carrera.
Para Alicia esto es muy fácil,
simplemente tengo que sustituir aquí
"t" igual a 0
y obtengo que la altura de Alicia
va a ser un tercio por 0...
por 0 más 5,
un tercio por 0 es simplemente 0,
así que la altura inicial de Alicia era 5 metros,
esa era la altura inicial de Alicia.
Ahora para Nicolás,
pues podemos hacer lo siguiente,
vamos a poner aquí de nuevo el tiempo.
Tiempo lo voy a anotar acá arriba,
y voy a poner aquí "n" de Nicolás si les parece bien.
Bueno y ¿qué sé?
yo sé que cuando el tiempo era de 6 segundos,
la altura de Nicolás era de 6 metros
y que cuando el tiempo era 8 segundos
8 segundos,
la altura de Nicolás era de 7 metros.
También sé,
que cuando el tiempo era 10 segundos,
entonces la altura era 8 metros,
y aquí puedo inferir lo siguiente,
me doy cuenta que
por cada dos segundos que pasan...
por cada dos segundos que pasan
aquí tengo un cambio de un metro,
en la altura de Nicolás,
aquí otra vez pasaron dos segundos
y tengo un cambio de un metro en la altura,
entonces puedo revertir este proceso y pensar,
bueno, si me voy dos segundos en el pasado,
llegó a cuatro segundos...
tendría que haber retrocedido un metro,
así que de seis pasaría a cinco
recuerden aquí voy a en reversa,
de 4 también puedo pasar a 2 segundos
y entonces,
estaría un metro más abajo, estaría en cuatro,
y finalmente en 0 segundos,
estaría a 3 metros de altura,
por lo tanto la altura de Nicolás,
sería de 3 metros
y sería menor que la de Alicia.
Ahora bien,
otro modo de contestar el mismo problema,
es plantear una ecuación para la altura de Nicolás,
así como tenemos una ecuación para la altura de Alicia.
Por ejemplo,
podría decir que la altura de Nicolás
como yo sé que están los dos
escalando a una velocidad constante,
donde está...
también lo hace con velocidad constante,
entonces la ecuación que describe su altura,
debe ser lineal
y entonces debe tener la forma "n",
la altura de Nicolás,
es igual a alguna constante "m",
que es esencialmente la velocidad
por el tiempo que ha transcurrido
más la altura inicial de Nicolás.
Entonces,
tienes "m",
pues va a ser la pendiente de la línea recta que
representa la gráfica de esta ecuación
o
otro modo expresarlo,
es "m" es la velocidad a la que Nicolás sube por el muro
y eso está dado,
por el cambio en la altura de Nicolás,
dividido entre el cambio
en algún intervalo de tiempo.
Estos dos tienen que estar ligados.
Bien, yo sé que
si el cambio en el tiempo es de dos segundos,
dígamos dos segundos,
entonces el cambio en la altura de Nicolás,
es de 1 metro...
es de un metro, por lo tanto Nicolás,
está subiendo una velocidad
de un metro cada dos segundos
o que la pendiente aquí,
es un medio,
de modo que si sustituyo esto
podría escribirlo como "n"
es igual a "m" pero "m"
es simplemente la velocidad de Nicolás,
que es un medio
"m" por un medio
por "t"
más la altura original de Nicolás
cuando "t" era igual a 0.
Ahora para encontrar esta "b",
simplemente sustituyo
cualquiera de estas parejas de puntos,
porque, si éste después de este tiempo
tiene que estar a esta altura,
por lo tanto podría poner por ejemplo,
si pongo,
la altura igual a 6, entonces,
6 tiene que ser igual
a un medio del tiempo,
el tiempo para la altura 6,
es 6 segundos,
así que un medio por 6
+ "b"
o lo que es lo mismo,
esto es 3 más "b"
de donde si igualo estas dos cosas
y resto 3 de ambos lados de la ecuación
obtengo que "b" es igual a 3,
de donde la ecuación de...
de la altura de Nicolás, sería "m" es igual a
un medio
del tiempo transcurrido
más 3
y si pongo aquí "t" igual a cero
obtengo que la altura original de Nicolás
en el muro era de tres metros.
Así que quien estaba más alto en el muro,
¿quien empezó la carrera
en un punto más alto del muro?
pues fue Alicia,
así que la segunda opción es la correcta.